[Musique]
le premier forum de solidarité organisée
par le département et edf s'est déroulée
ce lundi 15 avril dans l'hémicycle du
palais de la source était invité à cette
rencontre d'information les travailleurs
sociaux de la collectivité du secteur
nord les associations oeuvrant dans le
domaine des solidarités l'adil l'école
de la seconde chance
soit plus d'une centaine de personnes
réunies pour débattre sur des situations
rencontrées pour proposer des solutions
et s'informer tout le monde on apprenne
à mieux travailler ensemble parce que
nos départements bien sûr comporte une
loi de responsabilité dans
l'accompagnement des femmes en
difficulté mais tout seul n'arrivera pas
avec les deux problèmes il faut
travailler les uns les autres et dans
les dépenses des familles lien dépenses
qui est importante c'est dans les
dépenses de l'énergie de l'électricité
pour éclairer la maison pour alimenter
tous les biens d'équipement les voyez
vous quand cette facture elle est élevée
beaucoup de familles n'arrivent pas à
les payer et donc il nous convient de
travailler avec edf pour accompagner ces
familles
les indicateurs de pauvreté sont hors
normes avec 42% de la population
réunionnaise vivent en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté plus de 90 7000 foyers
bénéficiaires du rsa et un taux de
chômage avoisinant les 24 % des
dispositifs existent mais sont méconnus
par les ménages concernés
il y à la communication mais
mais insuffisante il faut c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on décide de se réunir
pour qu'on soit plusieurs à porter ces
messages là effectivement un client sur
cinq
éligible au chèque énergie ne
l'utilisent pas ça doit nous faire
réagir des dispositifs aide mais à nous
les simples dedic des dispositifs dave
existe mais ça nous les simplifier pour
que l'ensemble de nos clients qui sont
bénéficier
trois autres forums permettront de
présenter l'ensemble des aides et
dispositifs existants et s'articuleront
autour de trois axes majeurs
les solutions d'économie d'énergie
département espère énergie réunion et
services efficacité énergique d'edf
sensibiliseront aux offres agir plus
d'edf
les dispositifs d'être solidaire l'adil
le département le casse et les services
solidarité d'edf expliqueront les
modalités d'utilisation des plus de
140000 chèque énergie le digital au
service de la solidarité le département
et les équipes clientèle d'edf
présenteront les outils numériques comme
solution dead au client en difficulté
notamment le portail d'accès en ligne au
service solidarité d'edf
[Musique]